[音楽]
re re
さんは肘は
や小山乃里子です
今日は j 専之助とガンガーの端外してお話を聞いてもらえればと思います
n ハンガーは今年の4月に小学校1年生になりました
毎日英学校に行って新しいお友達をつくって帰ってきて毎日楽しいお話を聞かせてくれ
ます
カネ余りを上げなかったんですが
海でもプールでも感動を覚えるますが25m
上げるようになりました
にのことが大好きでの上がりを
います
冤罪の得るようになったんですけど自転車が誰を一番胸のですっごく小さいですけど
7の大事な思い出がいっぱい詰まってるから乗り換えたくないという
小さな自転車にドリフトに乗ってます
にのことが大好きでいつも金の話をしてくれます
私の息子な潤之介は小サイズ
付は破れずまで10カ月一人私のおなかの中でそうしました
とアイスが大好きでいつも毎日の in プリンを食べ
ムース家はラッコが大好きです黒たまごです
家族もちゃんの付を額をすることが大好きなのでいつもみんながやっちゃいますけど
取り合いをしています
もぅ
静かに私のが止めや私の口を
頑張ってい
聞いてくれる優しい息子ですっ
小雨になり大きくなりました
あんな寒いには4年前顔
6月に5歳です電子になりました
そんなを助けが生まれたとき
順応し家は呼吸をしていませんでした
生まれた時赤ちゃんが産まれる時って幸せに包まれてすごくハッピーなんだろうなぁと
思っていた私にとって
呼吸をして生まれてを教示ないのが出てきてすぐに顔を見ることもなく先生にソチに
連れて行かれてしまったとき
すごく悲しくて暗闇に残されたようなそんな気向けになりました
でも
ちゃんと呼吸をしてそこは頑張ってくれました
少しして先生から
空気の説明がありました
変わらない陽気で長くは生きられないかもしれないということ
けれど障害が残るということをお
n 2両で治らない病気があるなんてさすがその時
すみませんでした
波うちの子だったんだろう
チャンネルのすけだったんだろう
田中の中で何がいけなかったんだ工房と思いました
毎日何回も何回も発作をしました
学校してはに行くこともできなくて自
みるコールまずが開けることもできなくて
お風呂に入れたりおうちにつけて書いたり散歩をすることもできませんでした
毎日毎日辛い思いをする無効
助けてあげることも
できませんでした
私はままなのに
励ましてあげることができませんでした
おなかの中にいろんなものを忘れてきたのかな
そう思いました
可哀想だねとよく言われました
毎日毎日病気と闘う息子とを生活をしました
リハビリをして授業をして
雷手術をしたり毎日毎日お薬を飲ん月の底は
うんっ
頑張って戦いましたん
その髭等前に生活をする上に
預けなければ
私が学校してどこにも連れて行ってあげられることに気づきました
ご飯が食べれなければ形を変えてチューブから上げてあげれば
ハンバーガーだってーこの宮城だって食べることに気がつきました
目が見えなければ
私たちが綺麗な景色を伝えてあげればいうことに気づきました
毎日生活するうちに
一緒にいることがすごく幸せになりました
4歳になる頃には何回も何回も命の危険に
犬を繰り返し的です
側に一緒にいてくれるだけで幸せだということに本当に気が付きました
ただ私のまでの中にいてくれればいい
毎日一緒に過ごせればいい
そう思うようになってきました
でも
そんな小さな思いも叶いませんでした
周りの時期
朝起きた時者の事件は5級をするのをやめました
私はまだまだ一緒にいたかったし一緒にやりたいことがいっぱいありました
このまま冷たくなった15府県をダンプして逃げたらまだ一緒にいられるのかなとか
そんなことも考えました
だけど
坂本すごく小さかったのに
小さな小さな真っ白お生まれになった城介を見たときに
その後は5年間を本当に生き抜いたんだなと思いました
もう頑張らなくてもいいんだなと
いました
最初は何も出来ないと思ったけどあの子にはたくさんできることがありました
自分にできることだったらあの誰でもできるんじゃない
そう言われているような気がします
だから私は
淳之介てもできたスタンプは止めることにしました
病院から出れなくても
空の上にいても理解するところに住んでいても
彼らの参加ができます
手でも足でも手汗がなければほっぺでも体の一部のスタントでみんなが参加できます
ああああああ
最初は淳之介のお友達のスタンプを集めました
[音楽]
みんなのキャラ食べ成長感ですごくうれしかったです
me
[音楽]
友達が玉立に
機体に触れて担保が集めてくれますか
ああああああ
では皆さんからん
届きました
[音楽]
おっは
南部ストーンは鮫ながら費外注をしたいん
子どもたちのために何かをしたいと
その後は祈っに産後は抜けています
9ございまーちゃうん
私のしばしばのでで子どもたちの役に立つならと参加を時雨ません
戦争のある国も学校に行けない子供たちます
犬が参加して皆が応援してくれています
jins ができることでたくさんの人が2つ待って
みんなの力が集まれば大きなことができるんじゃないかそう思います
一人では小さな力です
お友達が10万人集まれば一人の声も10万人のポイントして届けることができます
一つ一つのスタッフには一つ一つのストーリーがあります
今日話ししたのは10万人のうちの1人の家族の私のお話です
短文の数だけお話があって
スタンプの数だけ家族の愛があります
小さな力が
そこに大きな家族の間つが上がってそれを応援したい人たちがみんなで取り組めばいい
からを変えることだってできるそう思います
私は10万人の仲間を探しています
9万人の皆外大きな絵をつくってパラリンピックを目指します
今日はご静聴ありがとうございました
ん